اعتمدت كرواتيا العمله الاوروبيه الموحده
اليورو والغت الاجراءات الحدوديه امام
حاملي جوازات السفر الاوروبيه وهكذا تنضم
البلاد الى منطقه شنجن التي تتيح التنقل
بلا تاشيرات بين 27 دوله في القاره اوصف
رئيس
الوزراءين بانهما هدفان استراتيجيان في
سياق الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
العاصمه الكرواتيه زهره تنضم الينا مراسله
الجزيره ستيفاني اهلا بك الاقتراب اذا
اكثر نحوه منطقه اليورو كيف تقيم السلطات
في كرواتيا سلبيات وايجابيات هذه الخطوه
خلال هذه المرحله
الرسميه لكرواتيا وهو سيدخلون ايضا منطقه
الشنغن وهذا يعني ان الحدود
مع كرواتيا لن يكون فيها اجراءات حدوديه
بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي ومن يحملون
تاشيره
هؤلاء يعتبروا الان استقبالهم امرا نافعا
اقتصاديا كرواتيا بالنسبه لقطاع الاعمال
وصادرات والواردات وبالنسبه للسياحه ايضا
في هذه الدوله تعتمد كثيرا على السياحه
ومعظم
السائحين ياتون عبر الحدود لزياره كرو سوف
يكون هناك صعوبات فيما يتعلق بتبني اليورك
لعمله الرسميه وعلى مدى الاسبوعين
القادمين يمكن الدفع بالعمله الحاليه وهي
الكونه هذا اليورو وهذه العمله القديمه
التي كانت قبل اسبوعين تستخدم الصعوبه هي
ان كل المحلات التجاريه وحتى الصغير منها
عليهم ان يعطوا الباقي باليورو حتى لو
دفعه الناس بالكونه اذن هذا قد يكون تحديا
كبيرا وايضا بنسبه للناس عليهم ان يتكيفوا
فهذا هذه العمله تعتبر جزء منه هويتهن اذا
هناك بعض الحزن يعبر عنه البعض اي خساره
العمله الحاليه وهذا يعتبر خساره جزء منه
هويتهم وايضا من نسبه للناس الكبار لديهم
مدخرات بالكون عليهم ان يقوموا ايضا
بتحويل هذه العمله
وتحويلها الى اليورو وهذا يعني ان
اخشى الان عليه ان يذهب الى السوق ويحمل
اله حساب من اجل ان يحسب كم ثمن كيلو
السكر مثلا في العمله الجديده اذا فهذه
الامور يتم الحديث عنها بانها تعتبر نجاحا
اقتصاديا وسياسيا هائلا
مزخرف عاصمه كرواتيا شكرا جزيلا لك